-I'm so happy
we're finally meeting in person.
I've been a fan of yours
for a long time.
The piece that I think first
put you on my radar is in 2014.
You were covering a Donald Trump
speech in New Hampshire.
This is when he was sort
of pretending to be a politician
or somebody
who might run for office.
-Yes.
-You then, because of a storm,
you ended up flying back
with him to Mar-a-Lago.
-Yes.
-And you wrote an article
about those 36 hours.
-I spent 36 hours marooned
at Mar-a-Lago with Donald Trump.
And, yes, I wrote a profile
[chuckles]
a 6,000-word story
about that time with him that,
suffice it to say,
he didn't not like.
But the piece --
kind of the gist of the piece --
because my whole takeaway
from him at that time
was that he was almost like
a tragic figure, you know?
He wanted so desperately
for me to take him seriously
as a political figure,
which I didn't.
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah. You --
-You know?
I know you can't relate to that.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah, exactly.
Well, I want to get to
our similarities.
But you forward the article,
which was for BuzzFeed --
you mocked up like a joke...
this was the joke picture...
-This -- Yeah.
...of him in the Oval Office,
and that's like
what it [bleep] looks like now.
[ Laughter ]
So I do want to get back
to the parallels we have,
which is that was sort of
a piece like you are --
you did not take him seriously.
In 2011,
at the Correspondents' Dinner,
I said, "You know, your --
it's a joke.
Your running is a joke."
-Yeah.
-How motivated as he is --
is he by dopes like us?
-Well --
Well, this is the thing.
I've -- We never met before,
but I've always felt
this kinship with you,
because we're like
part of this fraternity
of haters and losers...
-Yeah.
-...who questioned
Donald Trump's seriousness
as a candidate.
The thing that I've learned
about Donald Trump is that,
even though he was born with
all the wealth and privilege
he possibly could have had,
even though he's now president,
he's always felt like
he kind of has his face
pressed up against the glass.
Like, he feels like
he's an outsider
and that nobody
takes him seriously enough,
no one respects him.
The insiders
are all sneering at him.
I was actually told once
during the election --
this was after --
or right around the time
he was winning the primaries --
that I --
that article that I wrote
was one of the reasons
that he decided to run.
But -- But
that adviser told me that --
this is
a former Trump adviser --
told me that
you were higher on the list...
-Okay, well that --
-...on that list of reasons.
So...
-That...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
So...
[ Laughter and applause
continue ]
But he -- never let it be said
he is not a vengeful man --
that -- right? --
is it the night of
the convention he e-mailed you?
-Just -- Just a couple days
before the convention,
before he formally accepted
the Republican nomination,
I got an e-mail from him saying,
you know,
"McKay, you got it all wrong.
And just watch what's gonna
happen in the general election."
Like, "You got this all wrong.
I can't believe it."
That was what was going through
his mind,
you know, as he's winning
the Republican primary.
It's -- I think that people
don't understand
just how much
this matters to him,
just how much it matters to him
to prove the haters wrong,
to prove everyone wrong.
Even now, when he's in the --
in the Oval Office,
one of the things
that reporters are dealing with
when they cover this White House
is that you'll write a story
that's well sourced,
that's accurate
about some staffer
who's gonna be fired.
And because Trump will see it
reported, he'll change his mind,
just to be able to say,
"Look, that was fake news.
I got them wrong."
-Right.
-He's really motivated
by trying to disprove the press,
to disprove anybody who he
thinks is unfairly treating him.
-I want to talk about sourcing
real quick because, you know,
it seems like we hear so much
coming out of this White House,
more than, maybe,
we've ever had --
we've ever heard.
It is because,
from the very top,
he is a source that he is
talking to the press so often
that the people underneath him
feel the freedom to do the same?
-Yeah, absolutely.
You know, it's funny.
Like,
Trump does this thing where,
after his day's work is done,
he'll retire to the Residence
of the White House
and just kind of make
freewheeling phone calls
to, like, random people.
-Yeah.
-And, sometimes, they're,
like, fellow billionaire pals,
and, sometimes,
they're media people,
they're reporters.
And -- And it's funny --
I've had experiences with this
even when I was interviewing him
at Mar-a-Lago
where he'll be talking,
and he'll tell you a story,
and he'll be like, "Okay,
this part's off the record.
Well, now this part, just
attribute it to someone else,"
or whatever.
And he'll just --
he'll -- he'll be --
he'll just put random stuff
out there.
And that --
a lot of the stories you see
in -- in the press are --
it'll say like "somebody
familiar with the situation,"
or like
"a senior White House official,"
and it'll be the
President of the United States.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
A lurking, slow-moving
mass of a man.
[ Laughter ]
Did -- And do you think, like --
But that actually seems like
he's thinking about it
more than
we maybe give him credit for.
So, while he's telling a story,
he is at least aware enough
to know which parts to pull off
the record and on the record.
-Yeah, in my experience,
at least,
it was the parts
that he wanted me to write
that were flattering about him,
but he didn't want
to have it attributed to him.
-Got it.
-So, it'll be
like some heroic story about him
or a story about some celebrity
who said he was the greatest
ever of something, you know.
"But -- But
put that off the record.
Just don't use my name on that."
[ Laughter ]
-So he wants it out there,
but he wants it to seem like
it came from another source.
-He wants -- Exactly. Right.